in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Travis
and Abby are with us hey guys how are
you
we're doing good Dave how are you better
than we deserve welcome welcome good to
have you where do you guys live West
Lafayette Indiana Purdue University all
right very cool welcome to Nashville and
you're here to do your debt-free scream
we are with t-shirts that say get and
the other one says intense and the
little guy oh gizelle is in the middle
get gizelle intense I love it this is
Miss tinleigh and she's as excited as we
are all right miss Tenley way to go how
much debt have you guys paid off we've
paid off about eighty-seven thousand
dollars and around 25 months why did it
go
miking what kind of money well we
started out and ended at the same is
right around 130 thousand dollars
combined phenomenal what do you guys do
I'm a development officer for a pretty
University and she is a conference
coordinator for Purdue University as
well so she keeps everything right in
line so the Boilermakers keep you guys
alive I love it very cool well
congratulations so what kind of debt is
the eighty-seven thousand dollars well
what kind of debt wasn't everything we
we have the the big one which is Sallie
Mae at fifty one thousand dollars we had
two car loans that was thirteen thousand
the dreaded credit card which might have
been the free-spirit fault it was
fifteen thousand a little bit of medical
and a little bit of personal as well
yeah who would be the free spirit that
would be me that would be you that's
cool so tell me your story what happened
25 months ago that caused you to
completely turn your life on its head
because you guys did get ghazal intense
all right so what happened so we
actually Travis heard about Dave Ramsey
& Financial Peace University from a few
of his colleagues at Purdue and we were
actually getting ready to get married
and he came to me and said we got to pay
off all of our debt and I said now is
not the time a month before our wedding
and so I wasn't so thrilled about it and
we went actually went on our honeymoon
and put the entire thing on
credit-card mm-hmm in Mehta family on
some of the excursions we went on and
they were a family of five and every
excursion we know we put on the credit
card they were there every time and so
Travis is never afraid to talk to anyone
and so he asked them what's your secret
and they said have you ever heard of
Dave Ramsey and then we kind of looked
at each other and thought okay maybe
there's something to this and then we
came home got enrolled in a class and I
said that you know no offense Dave I'm a
huge fan now but in the beginning I said
there's no guy that's gonna tell me we
can't buy a house right after we get
married and after the first class of
Financial Peace University I looked at
him and I said honey we're not buying a
house not yet
yeah it's not until we're ready to do it
properly okay
very cool so you've been married two
years then huh a little more two years
all right and so coming back from the
honeymoon jumped in the class dove into
this Bato but absolutely absolutely we
you know miss Tenley came in we were
able to cash flow that we pressed pause
and we all got home safely we've pressed
play again and it was this the the piece
of doing that and not having medical
payments on top of you know our daily
life was just absolutely phenomenal so
thank you for that so what was the see
you just get married you come off the
honeymoon you go straight into Financial
Peace University instead of buying a
house you put that on hold until you get
your act together and so what's that
first budget meeting looked like was
that a big fight or you know I think
that we were both on the same page that
we wanted it to happen and we were so
excited about what our future had in
store for us but it was a lot of
confusion the very first budget planning
meeting as we were enrolled in Financial
Peace University you know you ask
sometimes you know did you do anything
that was weird and and that first budget
meeting to us felt very weird very
awkward
until we sat down and we'd never thought
that we had it right but it just as you
say you know it takes practice and every
month that got a little bit easier and a
little bit easier but it was it was a
little bit of a fight you're confident
that you feel today after doing it 26
times or 27 times now
we're budgeted up through January so we
feel pretty confident that we've got an
ability to go back and look at what
we've done in the past and predict the
future in terms of what expenses might
come up and you know our next goal is
we're just intense on the that given
that emergency fund set up in place so
that we can move forward so very
confident so so Abbey he called himself
the free spirit does that leave you
being the nerd you're the detail person
I would say I'm definitely in the detail
person but I will say he is you know he
might be drifting over to the other side
a little bit the nerd side sucked into
the dark side all right that's cool well
what happens is is that you know doing a
plan is all it amounts to regardless of
your personality bent is how you win and
so everyone does a plan it's just a
matter of how you kind of approach it
whether it's you naturally love details
or whether you're just willing to do
them in order to win and I don't
naturally do details but I'm willing to
do them in order to win so very cool
well congratulations so what's your big
advice to people you meet a couple who's
getting ready to get married and they
got 75 $100,000 for the dead hovering
around their heads combined they feel
probably kind of like y'all fell
probably overwhelmed probably a little
scared probably a little bit like we'll
never get out of this so what the heck
you know or just stuck what's your
advice to them on getting out of debt I
would say that the biggest thing that
helped us was living intentionally and
also providing each other grace
throughout the process because there
were some months where he was on it and
then there were other months where I was
like honey we're never gonna get there
knees like no we just got to keep going
we gotta keep going so I think that
you've got to have that grace for each
other and you've got a live intentional
and if you don't you know you've got to
have a plan set otherwise you're never
gonna know where you're gonna end up
going what about you Travis I would have
to say that you know looking back the
the 25 months it may seem like an
insurmountable task but when you get
laser focused and you really want this
for your life and for your family and
for your future
it is absolutely doable and when we look
back if
like just yesterday that we started this
journey and it was so worth it and there
were times where it felt slow but it is
so worth it and when you can forecast
the where your future is going to be
that's a that's an extremely gratifying
thing that's worth it you know you guys
are incredible young couple and what you
may or may not realize is you've
conquered one of the biggest problems in
marriage already and just been married
two years so I mean if you can conquer
this problem by working together you can
conquer almost anything that life throws
at you you're gonna be you're gonna be
an incredible incredible story as you
get older multi millionaires as well as
unbelievably generous there's gonna be a
lot of wonderful things happen in your
life I can see it coming congratulations
are very proud of you we do have one
thing we just want to give a shout out
we're leading the the momentum series
through our church crisis United
Methodist Church back in Lafayette
Indiana we have a few listeners we just
want to say you know you're doing great
work and keep it up and it's been a an
affirmation a reaffirmation of us of
what we're doing and relearning and re
going through it so we recommend anybody
if you but been through this process
become a coordinator try to get it going
in your church you choose more than get
it going with momentum you've got like
80% of your church going through it now
that's pretty incredible
we'll get there we didn't quite get 80%
the first round but it's catching on and
people are excited about what's
happening oh very very cool all right
Travis and Abbie from West Lafayette
Boilermakers Indiana and Tim all right
eighty-seven thousand dollars paid off
in twenty five months making a hundred
and thirty-eight year count it down
let's get a great debt free scream ready
three two one
I love it guys very very well done man
that is absolutely awesome